[Musique]
à l'expo habitations cette année l'été
congo aujourd'hui à des sauces pour
pâtes on aurait pu appeler
traditionnellement les sources de
lumière ce qui vas t'amuser c'est qu'on
dit rapport aux gens qu'on a une seule
source bat daniela la viande mais qu'on
a deux sources qui ne contiennent pas de
liant la bolognaise c'est le clasico on
a là comment ça l'est aussi la délice
d'autres fois on va voir ce que les gens
vont en penser
[Musique]
j'aimerais que la meilleure c'est la
bagarre mais j'aime la tienne si vous
vous êtes le fer avec tofu ou beau
bâtiment j'ai toujours fait avec la
viande et s'étaler jusqu'à moitié moins
six mois tu te fous moitié bien mais
lorsqu'on achète une sauce qui
contiennent la viande ou des protéines
végétales on s'attend que ce soit
justement plus rassasiants plus
nourrissant aussi donc on recherche des
protéines
on recherche des fibres donc des
éléments nutritifs là qui vont justement
combler certains besoins
on va rechercher minimalement ou 1,5 g
de protéines par 125 millilitres de
comme portion donc une demi-tasse puis 5
grammes c'est vraiment le minimum
[Musique]
élections ou à me dégoûter aussi la
jambe du retour bitcoin l'agente plus
élevée placent comme fer
[Rires]
du coup intéressant
là on est vraiment trop salée en termes
de sodium mais celle ci ne passe pas le
test parce qu'elle est trop salée est là
au dessus de 500 mg de sodium par
portion de la gueule
la viande pour la fin de la jambe large
en avion un jeu mais la pluie et à la
viande et le vert et bien non clientes
qui méduse et c'est la jonte et de la
viande est poignant dans savez-vous
laquelle et à la viande eh bien oui
qu'elle viendrait way
[Musique]
et délicieuse et épicé est bonne je la
droite ajoute à l'amiens la blood c'est
confirmé c'est ma préférée d'escale être
plus elle nous faudrait qu'il ya plus de
moins de viande ce qui concerne la
viande mais celle que vous aimez parce
qu'elle a beaucoup de bien le soya
contient un profil de protéines qui est
très intéressant et qui se compare un
peu aux protéines animales c'est à dire
que le soya à peu près tous les acides
aminés essentiels
etes-vous végétariens et végétaliens
carnivores ouais vous avez choisi celle
où je fus je vous dis que la bleue ya
pas de bien ma croyez-vous pas devient
c'est des manchots de tofu à l'intérieur
le tofu parce qu'il prend le petit les
saveurs dans lequel il est mélangé pas
il se dissimule aussi de cette façon là
la blouse de seulement six amateurs
le seul défaut c'est l'homme
ce qui est pas tout à fait assez
protéinée pour une portion d'un juste
trois grammes soit fissurée mais
franchement de deviner que tu te fut
dans cette source la faute de savoir
parce que c'est franchement s'en
aperçoit pas
[Musique]
elle a des lentilles chaque élève et des
solutions et
les verts c'est celle de commencer qui
est fait avec la farine de soya et les
lentilles mais jamais sur des shoots que
le goût un peu plus maison et lkp mais
c'est le
moi même
quand j'ai moins aimé
mais les émissions good bien que vous
avez choisi celle ci est végétarienne
celle de lentilles et de la farine de
soja qui passent le test de tous les
critères ben c'est la la comme en salle
et d'un point de vue nutritionnel en
tout cas donc elle à l ai pas trop salée
elle a quand même suffisamment trotter
ce fut un test de goût tout aussi
amusants qu'intéressant onze personnes
ont bien aimé la sauce commence à ils
pressent mexico la clasico a récolté 19
voix mais une vingtaine ont préféré la
délice d'autrefois
merci beaucoup à tout le temps